puppetry green screen trickery and a
fake version of an unmistakably
recognizable Metropolis this is how I Am
Legend was transformed by its special
effects in an early sequence Dr Robert
Neville takes a joy ride in his Mustang
through the wreckage of the city the
former Metropolis of New York City is
now Wide Open Country this section
culminates with a stunt in which Neville
swerves to avoid some deer crossing the
road according to the behind the-scenes
footage this proved to be one of the
most complicated scenes to produce first
it required clearing large sections of
Manhattan then in order to capture Will
Smith in the shots without relying on a
blue screen the filmmakers used an at
the time technologically advanced setup
that involved a Stunt Driver controlling
the car from an attached pod with the
actor in the front seat this then
required heavy CGI work to remove the
equipment planted on the car which is
the say nothing of all the other VFX
needed to transfer this sequence into
the world of I Am Legend it's definitely
advancing uh
technologically entering Time Square in
I Am Legend marks the moment when
viewers really feel the scope of the
damage that the virus has caused the
busiest part of the city that never
sleeps looks utterly abandoned which
sets the stage for everything else to
come when Neville creeps through the
grass while approaching the overgrown
post-urban space we get to see the Time
Capsule created by the apocalypse
despite shooting in New York City for a
good portion of the production the I Am
Legend team couldn't actually clear the
realtime Square for these sequences so
they were shot instead on a Sound Stage
which allowed for a controlled
environment practical effects and props
brought the tall grass and some cars to
life while the team relied on digital
effects for everything else one of the
most noticeable bits of visual rendering
in I Am Legend is undoubtedly the
animals even though humanity is all but
wiped out a number of other creatures
continue to live in nature the deer in
particular look like CGI creations and
that's that's because they are in one
early sequence we see them running
together in a large herd which tends to
really accentuate the sense of The
Uncanny Valley the one exception to this
rule is Neville's dog Sam played by Kine
actors Abby and Kona the rest of the
movies infected dogs were added in
digitally although for scenes where Will
Smith interacted with them a puppet
helped elicit a physical reaction from
the actor you know I don't like
surprises in the opening shots of I Am
Legend director Francis lawren treats us
to a bird's eyye view of Manhattan this
represents just one of the many
establishing moments that help
illustrate the Decay and breakdown of
the world since the viral outbreak 3
years earlier VFX artists handled pretty
much all of that hard work in Total Sony
Pictures imageworks delivered more than
800 visual effect shots in order to make
Manhattan appear convincingly lifeless
and worn the VFX team added broken
windows collapsed rubble and overgrown
plants to exterior shots of the city all
signs of life in the original shots
needed to be taken out including cars
pedestrians birds and pretty much
whatever else you can think of so much
intricate movie Magic was required to
clean or dirty up the frames vegetation
was added as it spread out over the
street these effects combin with the
darker and moodier color palette to
complete an image that feels completely
different from what the camera initially
captured here's another remarkable CGI
shot from the establishing sequences it
presents footage of a dilapidated NYC in
the form of a full Highway and skyline
of the entire city to get the end
product right dozens of moving cars and
vehicles were removed from the original
shot what began as a regular look at a
busy City skyline was completely
transformed into an abandoned highway
even better a pile of junk cars
eventually took up the space that was
once used to travel and the whole street
was flooded to make it completely
unusable this image serves as a reminder
of the chaos of the night of the
outbreak and how Humanity destroyed
itself the scene featuring Neville at
the financial district South Street
Seaport which he visits daily to check
if anyone heed his call for other
survivors boasts some of I am Legend's
most complex background VFX for the
shots filmed on location the city
looming in the background provides an
important aspect of the framing and
photography that presented some
challenges to the VFX Artist as it
needed to now reflect the destruction in
the rest of the city in fine detail
across the backgrounds of each of these
shots to make this work a mat painter
created 2.5d elements that added fire
damage and broken windows to assorted
buildings this matte painting layer was
then superimposed on top of the
backgrounds from the shot itself it also
required the VFX artist to drop in
elements that the filmmakers wanted in
the background that didn't actually
appear in the original shots including a
bridge and highways
please you are not alone when nil
happens upon an abandoned Mobile station
to siphon some gas from the pumps we get
another glance at an everyday location
that normally wouldn't be remarkable in
any way what's interesting about this
moment before and after the effects has
little to do with the overgrown rusted
gas station itself CGI was deployed most
noticeably here to drape a giant plastic
tarp over what appears to be a
previously quarantined building back
when there were people to quarantine on
the tarp is a symbol implying that this
building was once used as a containment
site this is a visual effects touch that
makes the environment more visually
interesting in a way that elevates the
storytelling and World building this
background image serves to drive home
the notion that the city and its denisen
went through hell not too long ago an
early flashback sequence reveals Dr
Neville's location on the night of the
outbreak as well as what he lost that
Day filming and editing this sequence in
a way that ultimately made sense in the
finished product proved to be a huge
hurdle
the issue was that the pier that Neville
and his family evacuated from didn't
actually exist in the New York City of
2007 so production brought in a barge
and attached it to the Shoreline which
was quite a massive undertaking the
evacuation establishing shot had to be
recorded in two pieces and stitched
together which required rendering a
three-dimensional FDR Drive and Brooklyn
Bridge with special effects in the scene
military forces Patrol the road to bring
them in actors had to First be shot on a
green screen and then later their images
were added to the final composite image
this sequence ended up being almost
entirely a digital collage of film
making magic not in spite of how
realistic it looks but because of that
to pull that one off require the
cooperation of city state and federal
agencies I think to a degree
unprecedented in New York the evacuation
ultimately goes very wrong for Neville
and his family after being separated
from his wife Zoe and daughter Marley
he's forced to stay on the island to
help the military in the ensuing chaos
of the bridges being bombed to stop the
spread of the virus Zoe and Marley are
killed in a helicopter accident in one
particular shot the bridge collapse can
be seen in the form of a flaming wreck
in order to make this happen the VFX
artist first had to remove the bridge
entirely from the initial shots that
were recorded then the entire Brooklyn
Bridge had to be added in with VFX only
for it to then be destroyed since they
were shooting location and couldn't
actually destroy a bridge this was the
best workaround thus the bridges were
first removed from the shots and then
rendered entirely in 3D so that the
sequence could benefit from the most
explosive and heartbreaking results
possible another memorable sequence
features dozens of dark Seekers
attacking Neville as he sits in a
minivan a behind thes scenes feature on
the special edition Blu-ray refers to
this scene as the nighttime demolition
derby it looks like it was shot in New
York but it was actually rendered
entirely on a green screen most of the
elements outside the car were added
digitally making this one of I am
Legend's most special effects heavy
scenes in the scene Neville is angrily
driving as he tries to get the dark
Seekers off his ride the entire
environment needed to be computer
generated this consisted of many
disperate technical aspects including a
360° map painting for the background CG
water and CG Bridges and highways
naturally all the infected creatures
attacking Neville were also CG the only
practical props in the scene are the car
itself and the telephone pole that comes
crashing down some movie goers might
remember I Am Legend for its gripping
action While others look back fondly at
its ahead of its time CGI and still
others recall it only for the scene
where the dog dies here's how the
tragedy goes down Neville and his German
Shepherd companion Sam cross a bridge
and are attacked by a pack of infected
canines Neville walks away without a
scratch but Sam isn't so lucky there's
one moment when one of the dogs tackles
Neville and starts chomping at his face
in order to make the stakes feel as
dangerous as possible a puppet of the
dog's face and mouth was used a behind
the-scenes clip reveals an actor in a
green screen suit holding a doghead
puppet special effects were added
afterward to remove the actor and
complete the dog's torso thereby giving
it a completely different look from the
vicious puppet this explanation could
potentially turn a pretty intense scene
into just a silly moment moment of two
grown men playing with puppets but that
do head is pretty darn scary Samantha
just got to get you home while I Am
Legend was pretty successful at the time
it came out some aspects of the movie
admittedly haven't aged that well years
after the release the full CGI dark
Seekers look awkward and silly in
certain lighting but going the VFX route
wasn't always the plan initially
director Francis Lawrence wanted to use
actors wearing Prosthetics and makeup to
play each of the dark Seekers on screen
parkour Specialists were even hired and
trained before Lawrence realized that
the visual Direction didn't feel
convincing or menacing enough he then
worked out a combination of animation
and motion capture motion capture was
still used as a base for the movements
of the creatures but supplemental
animations made their performances feel
more erratic and creature-like the
film's VFX unit also needed to devise
the translucent appearance of the dark
seeker's infected skin to do this each
darkseeker model contained three meshes
or layers the thin translucent layer of
skin the musculature beneath and the
skeleton for lighting purposes making
sure that these creatures looked
convincing in all lights was key to
pulling off this successfully but with
hindsight it might not have hit the mark
completely I am Legends VFX artists
created two models that all the other
dark Seekers were copied from the alpha
male and female were based on facial and
motion capture performances using the
these two scans six body types were
digitally built for the infected human
characters secondary characteristics
were then generated in order to create
the 43 distinct digital models that
reappear throughout the film this meant
that Will Smith didn't always act
opposite physical bodies while shooting
scenes with the infected creatures but
there was at least one in which he acted
alongside the motion capture performer
when Neville tests the would be cure on
an infected woman the audience watches
along with them hoping against hope that
that it will work that is until she
starts to thrash about in a behind thes
scenes feature it's revealed that an
actual woman in a motion capture suit
performed this stunt on set however
other scenes like the demolition derby
would have been impossible to film
safely even using motion capture hence
why CGI was so useful for capturing the
scale of
production